mon père est malade tant qu'on n'a pas
fait la grande cérémonie il est encore
parmi nous
rendre visite
permets-moi de te le présenter
c'est un ami qui vient de loin
[Musique]
elle se tient au côté d'Alain Delon dans
l'ombre de la star cette femme
iromirolin une présence quotidienne
aujourd'hui dénoncée par les enfants de
l'acteur ils ont déposé deux plaintes
notamment pour abus de faiblesse et
harcèlement moral leur avocat explique
elle contrôle systématiquement ces
conversations téléphoniques et ses
messages privés elle répond à sa place
en se faisant passer pour lui elle
empêche ses enfants de venir le voir
régulièrement c'est mon père à
l'intérieur
il est pas mal il est mort
pour nous il dort il se repose
alors là ça c'est votre papa ça c'est
papa
c'est mon père ils se sont connus sur
des plateaux de tournage avant de vivre
ensemble après la vessie de l'acteur en
2019 sur cette photo prise il y a
quelques semaines main dans la main ils
apparaissent complices lors d'une
projection
qualifiée de femmes de compagnies par
les enfants d'Alain Delon l'acteur lui
la décrivait comme sa compagne lors
d'une interview il y a deux ans
et ça fait combien de temps qu'il est là
maintenant ça fait quatre ans qu'il est
malade quand le garde là
quatre ans ça fait quatre ans qu'il est
là dans votre maison
Lacanau dans les Landes rejetons-nous en
l'océan a fait reculer la côte 1200
logements une centaine de commerces et
d'industrie des routes 40% de la station
balnéaire a dû déménager
toujours en 2050 dans les Alpes la
station d'avoria doit faire face au
manque de neige à 1800 mètres d'altitude
la saison de ski est plus courte trois
semaines de moins qu'aujourd'hui mais
quel endroit
je vois qu'il y a déjà des il y a des
gens qui ont laissé des bananes vous
avez amené quoi vous
on a emmené des œufs des œufs
et des carottes donc c'est un volcan
plutôt végétarien oui c'est ça
2050 sur la Côte d'Opale la mer est
montée de 25 cm lors des grandes marées
l'eau poussée par le vent envahit la
célèbre promenade des planches de
Deauville une élévation de l'océan qui
pourrait s'amplifier à la fin du siècle
si on ne se limite pas en termes
d'émissions de gaz à effet de serre on a
des scénarios qui impliquent un
effondrement de certaines parties de la
calotte glacière Antarctique qui nous
amène autour de 1 m 7 en 2100
d'élévation au niveau de la mer il n'a
jamais fait aussi chaud sur terre que
cette semaine la planète a connu lundi
et mardi les deux journées les plus
chaudes jamais enregistrées par les
météorologues en fait lundi 17 degrés 01
mardi record à nouveau battu 17 degrés
18 données fournie par l'agence
américaine d'observation océanique et
atmosphérique et c'est un constat qui
inquiète les scientifiques
comme toujours sur les chantiers ça
c'est international il y a ceux qui
bossent et ceux qui regardent
sur une plage bondée de Floride un
requin apparaît au milieu des baigneurs
sortez sortez de l'eau cette fois-ci
heureusement le requin ne mord pas et
repart où est-ce qu'il est allé il y a
encore quelqu'un de ce côté-là
plus au nord l'aller-retour requin est
active sur les plages de New York en
quelques jours les squale ont mordu 5
fois ses vacances ne sont pas synonymes
de dépaysement pour tout le monde selon
un sondage réalisé par l'institut
cluster un Français sur deux ne partira
pas un choix subi pour la moitié d'entre
eux qui évoque des raisons budgétaires
sans surprise les ouvriers sont trois
fois plus nombreux que les cadres à ne
pas pouvoir partir
quand j'ai vu les dents de la mer au
cinéma j'ai eu tellement peur que je ne
me suis pas baigné pendant 10 ans et
maintenant qu'il y a des vrais requins
près des plages je ne vais pas y
retourner de sitôt
moi je prends le risque
certains comme François Ruffin
souhaitent l'instauration d'un droit dit
aux vacances
les enfants travaillent 3 à 4 heures par
jour
grâce à eux la famille Casa arrive
difficilement à gagner 250 euros par
mois
continue
n'importe quel boulot même balayeur
vous avez vu la délinquance dans ce pays
avec ce spot publicitaire Jackie Chan
pensait maîtriser l'art de l'émotion
aussi bien que l'art martial alors qu'il
visionne ses propres cascades avec une
actrice qui incarne sa fille pour faire
la promotion de son nouveau film
papaye
si nos jeunes pouvaient imaginer une
bonne fois pour toute que s'il y a des
gens qui n'auront jamais honte de ce
sont leurs parents vous pouvez tout dire
à vos parents on est prêt à tout
entendre quand on est parents et surtout
à pas vous laisser dans la détresse donc
quel que soit la bêtise qu'on peut faire
quel que soit l'erreur qu'on peut
commettre je pense qu'il y a aucun il y
a aucun risque à parler à ses parents
bien au contraire si certains ont été
émis d'autres se sont indignés car dans
la vraie vie la star du cinéma chinois
aurait rejeté sa propre fille il y a
quelques années en raison de son
orientation sexuelle
découvrez son incroyable transformation
en bon père de famille
[Musique]
sérieux
prochainement sur paramont plus
Véronique parce qu'il voulait pas faire
cette émission mais dès qu'il aperce la
caméra il fait
on voit bien c'est la vérité il s'agit
de la perquisition du domicile de
yefghani frigogine réalisé fin juin à
Saint-Pétersbourg on y voit la demeure
du chef du groupe Wagner et son
hélicoptère posé dans le jardin à
l'intérieur des pièces luxueuses dans
lesquelles les enquêteurs auraient
découvert des armes plusieurs passeports
des liasses de billets et même des
lingots d'or mais également cette photo
montrant des têtes tranchées et c'est
énorme masse l'un des emblèmes du groupe
paramilitaire pourquoi on vous surnomme
apo
il paraît il parait c'est pas moi qui
l'ai décrété mais que j'ai encore
d'Apollon un corps d'apollon carrément
ah ouais avec la planche de surf les
cheveux blonds dans le ventre tout ça
c'est vaut mieux entre Apollon et Shrek
vaut mieux être surnommé Apollon autre
découverte plus insol cette armoire
pleine de perruques et ses photos où
l'on voit prigogines se déguiser pour
passer inaperçu pour certains cette
opération de communication orchestrée
par le Kremlin vise à ridiculiser
l'oligarque russe une volonté
effectivement de décrédibiliser
pour potentiellement l'écarter
définitivement à la Maison Blanche une
mystérieuse poudre blanche qui a été
retrouvée et après analyse c'est
confirmé il s'agit bien de cocaïne une
enquête a été ouverte pour déterminer
qui a apporté la drogue